what are sapiens institute doing what
are they doing
i can't see what they're doing i can't
see it many times the most impactful
work is being done behind the scenes
social media can sometimes paint a false
veneer on what really matters and
instead of striving for impact
we start chasing vanity metrics
serbian institute has been very
cognizant of this and that is why from
our very inception
we decided to focus on impact we did
this by formulating and delivering
various programs to empower
educate and mentor leaders to share and
defend islam academically and
intellectually
you might be aware of the fruits of some
of these programs but not aware
that sapience was behind them in the
world famous blue mosque in istanbul
which is estimated to have almost 4
million
visitors annually there is an office
responsible for providing visitors
with information about the dean sapiens
delivered an advanced dao training
course to
the volunteers of the blue mosque in
istanbul
not only did they learn about effective
academic intellectual arguments about
the dean
but also they learned techniques and
initiating conversations with visitors
of the mosque
using emotional intelligence along with
cultural sensitivity
that is impact our instructors have
officially delivered advanced training
courses to imams
students from medina university and from
various dark rooms
brothers and sisters this is just the
tip of the iceberg sapiens
impact is being felt all around the
world
even if you don't see us click the
button now and donate and don't forget
to share
the video